I haven't been saying almost anything
about political endorsements this cycle
and people who have been watching or
listening to the show for a while
probably can guess why which is that I
do not believe that political
endorsements really matter at least not
the vast majority of them and
particularly not this far into a
democratic primary where there have been
so many debates it's been going on for
so long most people are so familiar with
the candidates and even those who are
not are not particularly going to be
making decisions on the basis of one
endorsement or another in a way that
could move the needle and I've said
before that that's really the key think
the needle doesn't get moved that much
by endorsements endorsements are the
type of thing that endorsements from
media outlets generate more media about
the endorsements but they don't really
move the needle very much that being
said they can be interesting to look at
because they do tell us some interesting
things about what the establishment
might be thinking or what legacy
corporate media thinks or we might look
at reactions to endorsements which can
sometimes tell us something interesting
about a race and that's the case with
the New York Times endorsements that
were made yesterday after a whole bunch
of fanfare and pomp and circumstance and
releasing of little video excerpts of
the interviews that the New York Times
did with each of the different
Democratic candidates the New York Times
opinion page has issued its endorsement
and they have broken with convention
they've decided to endorse two
candidates now importantly I saw tweet
saying they endorsed a ticket in in
endorsing two candidates they did not
the New York Times says that they are
endorsing two separate candidates not a
ticket that should run together and
those candidates are Amy Klobuchar and
Elizabeth Warren the New York Times
points out that they spent a whole bunch
of time with the candidates that this is
a key choice for Democrats who want to
defeat Trump and so on and so forth
giving context for why this is the way
they decided to do it and their
conclusion is that the most effective
candidates for each of the two
approaches
that they say Democrats could choose our
Elizabeth Warren and Amy Klobuchar so
the two approaches you can probably
guess are a more progressive approach
where they are saying it's Warren not
Bernie that Democrats should go with and
a more centrist establishment approach
we're they're saying it is globish are
not Joe Biden or Pete Budaj edge that
they should go with these are my words
in terms of calling them the progressive
and the centrist as I interpret with the
New York Times writes they use other
phraseology there's a paragraph also
about Bernie Sanders being 79 at
inauguration time they mentioned that he
had a heart attack and they also write
that Bernie's lack of compromising and
over-promising is a reason why the
progressive choice should not be Bernie
it should be Warren if Democrats say
that's the way they want to go they say
quote Mr Sanders would be 79 when he
assumed office and after an October
heart attack his health is a serious
concern then there's how Mr Sanders
approaches politics he boasts that
compromise is anathema to him only his
prescriptions can be the right ones even
though most are overly rigid untested
and divisive he promises that once in
office a groundswell of support will
emerge to push through his agenda three
years into the Trump administration we
see little advantage to exchanging one
over promising divisive figure in
Washington for another good news then
they say that Elizabeth Warren has
emerged as a standard bearer for the
Democratic Left and the New York Times
goes on to list a bunch of different
reasons why they say Warren is the way
to go for the progressive choice rather
than Bernie as they those are first of
all she is a gifted storyteller in terms
of how the system is rigged now notice
that each a lot of these prose are
thinly veiled digs at Bernie so when
they say she's a gifted storyteller
about how the system is rigged which
feels less bombastic than other ideas
that's a reference to Bernie Bernie is
due
other language and is applying bombast
which they are being implicitly critical
of they say they like that Elizabeth
Warren is committed to reform rather
than tearing down and rebuilding it
which is more the burning approach very
early on I did a story about even if on
policy they are similar on many issues
Bernie and Warren have some real
differences one of those differences is
the approach the idea of Elizabeth
Warren reforming the things not working
about the system
Bernie tearing down the system and
rebuilding it altogether when you read
between the lines in this bullet point
about how Warren is committed to reform
is a thinly veiled or maybe not so
thinly veiled critique of Bernie Sanders
they say campaign policy plans are
serious when it comes to Elizabeth
Warren it seems to be an implication
that maybe they see Bernie's campaign
plans is not so serious
they also say Elizabeth Warren should be
the progressive choice for the
Democratic Party because she will
increase federal investment in clean
energy research shall we nests off of
fossil fuels
she will expand Universal childcare free
public college and Social Security so
then there is wike low bashar for the
moderate centrists and the New York
Times points out that if you want to go
with a more establishment candidate a
more centrist candidate that even though
Biden is winning the polls it's only
because of familiarity more than
anything else and that Biden's age is a
sign that he should be passing the torch
and they say that it is Amy Klobuchar
who should have the torch pass to her
they say quote good news then that Amy
Klobuchar has emerged as a standard
bearer for the Democratic Center her
vision goes beyond the incremental given
the polarization in Washington and
Beyond the best chance to enact many
progressive plans could be under a clova
shower administration they go on to
explain the senator from Minnesota is
the very definition of Midwestern
charisma grit and stick-to-itiveness her
lengthy tenure in the Senate and
bipartisan credentials would make her a
deal maker a real one and uniter for the
wings of the party and perhaps the
nation you know in
looking at the reaction to amy klobuchar
during the debates and looking at how
the progressive left reacts to her I
don't know that she would actually be a
uniter of the wings of the party but
again this is the New York Times
assessment of this what they are
effectively saying is she's slightly
more progressive than Biden she's
younger and from a practical perspective
she might get more done so this is the
endorsement of the New York Times two
options progressive or centrist if you
want to go progressive the New York
Times says take Warren if you want to go
centrist the New York Times says take
amy klobuchar so here's the deal I don't
think the New York Times has any
responsibility to choose people they
think will win so as an example Amy
Klobuchar has no shot she's continuing
to poll three percent nationally sees
she's in fifth place place in Iowa and
likely will get 0 delegates there she's
in fifth place in New Hampshire and is
not going to get any delegates there
she's in seventh place in Nevada in
South Carolina Amy Klobuchar is polling
worse than people who are no longer even
in the race Cory Booker in South
Carolina he's out of the race he's
polling better than Amy Klobuchar so I
don't think that that matters when it
comes to who they endorse endorse
whoever they think is best based on
whatever metrics they're applying not
who they think they will win
so they endorsed Klobuchar if Dems want
to go centrist and Warren if Dems want
to go progressive the real problem I
have is that they seem to be ignoring
the actual records of candidates in
their assessments so when they say if
the Democratic Party wants to go left go
with Warren over Bernie they frame
Bernie as a simply my way or the highway
type of guy when in reality Bernie
Sanders has had many successes
negotiating with Republicans in the
Senate the New York Times has even
written articles about Bernie successes
negotiating with Republicans in the
Senate Amy Klobuchar on the other hand
is not really a more progressive version
of Joe Biden in any real practical sense
look at her record voting for Trump's
horrible extremist judges recently which
again the New York Times is also covered
as has The Daily Beast and we are
showing you an article talking about
that so the real issue for me is you
know endorse whoever you want that
there it's their endorsement right it's
not mine we can disagree about the
strategy behind it but the problem is
that they are using incorrect assertions
they are basing their endorsements on
facts that are not really facts and what
I believe that they did is they decided
who they were going to endorse first and
they worked backwards to justify it they
decided we want to endorse Warren over
Bernie so let's find a way of justifying
it and they said well Warren's more
pragmatic Bernie isn't my way or the
highway guy Bernie will be 79 when
inauguration comes they backed their way
in it's like a post facto
rationalization to get to where it is
they decided initially they wanted to
get let's endorse flow which are over
Biden we can say Biden's age and that
his time has passed but we'll ignore a
whole bunch of stuff about Klobuchar and
we'll be able to justify the
endorsements we want to make anyway and
if you watch the videos I know that
these are only excerpts but go and watch
the videos when they are actually
interviewing the different candidates
and look at their demeanor to the
candidates that they ended up not
endorsing watch the interview with
Bernie Sanders and honestly tell me that
they seemed actually open to endorsing
Bernie Sanders that's not what I saw
when I watched it this is not anything
other than saying I believe that these
endorsements were decided upon maybe not
explicitly they might not have said it
but they knew where they wanted to go
with them and they built a case around
that more like a defense attorney or a
prosecutor rather than simply being a
juror and saying let's look at all the
facts and then come to our conclusion in
the end I still don't think this matters
but I want to hear from you about it
what do you think is the goal of the New
York Times endorsements particularly
when Amy Klobuchar has no chance of
winning do you think it is posturing of
some kind do you think it is more meant
to just muddle things up in a in a way
that will end up being pro-establishment
whatever you think about the
endorsements I want to hear from you if
you're watching on YouTube
leave a comment replying to this video
if you're not send me a tweet on Twitter
at D Pakman while you're there
follow the
show on Twitter as well at david pakman
show we've got a lot to discuss on the
first day of donald trump's senate
impeachment trial i know that the david
pakman show audience is full of curious
and creative people who love learning
new things and bettering themselves and
that's why i'm so excited to tell you
about one of our sponsors Skillshare the
vibrant online learning community that
offers thousands of classes on almost
any topic you can imagine and you'll get
full access to the entire library of
classes for two entire months free when
you go to david pakman.com slash skill
all of the classes are taught by experts
in their fields they've got classes on
drawing painting photography video
editing web design bookkeeping marketing
personal productivity doesn't even
scratch the surface I recently took a
class about photography if anybody
follows me on Instagram you know that my
photography skills leave much to be
desired and it was great I got so much
out of it and hopefully you will see the
fruits of me taking that class reflected
in my Instagram pictures sooner than
later they have classes for every skill
level whether you're wanting to get
better at something you already have
experience with you want to learn
something totally new to you you set
your own pace classes are usually less
than an hour long they're divided up
into bite-size segments so you can
easily fit them into your schedule make
2020 a year where you explore new skills
deep in existing passions get lost in
creativity Skillshare really makes it
easier than ever
Skillshare memberships are less than ten
bucks a month and that gives you access
to the thousands of classes they offer
but everybody in the David Pakman show
audience gets a Skillshare membership
totally free for two whole months just
go to david pakman.com slash skill
that's david pakman.com slash s ki ll